wir kennen alle den versandriesen amazon
und die liefern schnell aber manchmal
auch wirklich sehr sehr komisch wir
haben wirklich unfassbare bilder
bekommen von zuschauern
die haben das mit ihrer kamera ihre heim
kamera mit der überwachungskamera
aufgezeichnet und wir schauen mal in das
erste video rein traute seinen augen
kaum während der soldat auf arbeit war
schlug die app der überwachungskamera
auf seinem handy alarm
brisant das video zeigt einen amazon
boten wie er die ware aus dem kleinen
päckchen einsteckt taipeh ist schockiert
sagt ich hatte eine geldbörse für 40
euro und eine handy hülle besteht die
geldbörse hat er geklaut die plastik
handy hülle zugestellt der soldat meldet
den fall amazon beim ersten anruf wurde
mir lediglich der betrag der ware gut
geschrieben sagte er
erst beim zweiten anruf versprach man
sich demnach um den diebischen fahrer zu
kümmern
ein sprecher von amazon zeit auf bild
anfrage mit dass es sich um einen
ausnahmefall handeln würde der liefer
fahrer würde in zukunft keine amazon
pakete mehr liefern
amazon hat nach eigener aussage kontakt
mit dem kunden aufgenommen um es wieder
gutzumachen
deutlich zu sehen schwupps ist die
geldbörse weg und das paket wird einfach
so durch den schlitz geschoben
irre oder frank zander ich meine das
sind ja nur kleine fälle aber der
besitzer von amazon einer der reichsten
männer der welt
den interessiert das nicht das geht am
nächst höhere oder das ist aber ist uns
sehr unternehmen das genau in unserem
fall aber den fall werden wir jetzt
erstmal nicht weiter sondern wir
unterziehen schwere ja ist klar die
emotionen gehen hoch verstehe ich auch
tatsächlich an kempkens wirklich einen
ihrer fall wie kann ich denn wie ist die
rechtslage wie kann ich denn da
nachweisen dass da das paket möglicher
weise geöffnet wurde
also das ist ja tatsächlich ein kurioser
fall von ersatzzustellung und zwar
ersatzzustellung paketbote an paketbote
und man sollte wenn man so pakete
bekommt immer darauf achten
dass man eine ersatzzustellung an
nachbarn oder so er widerspricht man
sollte also eher darauf bestehen dass
das eben nur einem selber zugestellt
wird denn wenn man mit einer
ersatzzustellung einverstanden ist
beispielsweise bei den nachbarn was sie
auch vielfach gemacht wird natürlich
dann ist das paket zugestellt und das
ist dann ein bisschen problematisch wenn
es dann verschwindet von daher sollte
man immer ganz genau gucken wer soll
denn das paket bekommen das kann man
beim bestellen auch eben selber
bestimmen und das eben so ein bisschen
im hinterkopf behalten und das war das
eine video und kurze zeit später hat uns
ein anderer zuschauer aus braunschweig
noch ein anderes unfassbares video
geschickt wiederum spielt ein aber so
ein zusteller die hauptrolle unter
schauen wir mal rein
als es wieder ein überwachungsvideo und
man denkt erst mal was passiert da jetzt
und tatsächlich geht es auch gleich los
der amazon zusteller betritt dann gleich
die szene und wir schauen uns gemeinsam
an irgendwas was dann passiert man achte
auf das päckchen was auf dem auf der
obersten stufe liegt der amazon fahrer
kommt schaut sich das dort liegende
päckchen an klingelt und sagt es und was
passiert jetzt noch ist alles im grünen
bereich er guckt durch die tür oder
durch die fenster offenbar keiner da
was macht er jetzt jetzt legt er diesen
brief dort ab und geht nein er geht
nicht er wendet sich dem päckchen zu was
dort liegt guckt noch mal schaut und
endet mit der amazon fahrer nimmt ein
völlig fremdes päckchen mit wir haben in
dem fall recherchiert tatsächlich waren
in dem in der amazon silvan knopfzellen
also kleine mini batterien und in dem
paket was dort lag waren sehr
hochwertige kopfhörer im wert von über
200 euro waren nicht bei amazon bestellt
wann bei einem anderen versendern
dorthin geliefert einfach vor der tür
abgestellt und plötzlich sind zwar die
batterien da aber die hochwertigen
kopfhörer fehlen am camp jetzt haben sie
sogar schon mal gesehen
ja das erleben wir leider in der letzten
zeit häufig
der markt wird ja immer größer das ist
aber keine zulässige zustellung das
heißt die kopfhörer
die wollen erst hier beim haus abgelegt
wurden und die dann der zweite boote
mitgenommen hat die gelten nicht als
zugestellt
das bedeutet dass sozusagen der
versender das risiko des verlustes
übernimmt weil man das ja hier bestellt
hat bei einem unternehmer und wenn das
paket jetzt entwendet wird auf diesem
weg bevor das sozusagen in den
machtbereich des empfängers eingeht dann
ist das nicht zugestellt das heißt der
kunde bekommt ihr neues paket ihm kann
es so zu sagen egal sein risiko
übernimmt der absender
tatsächlich aber die frage es ist ja die
rede von einer abstell genehmigung das
kann man zum beispiel bei dhl auch im
internet beantragen dann ermächtige ich
quasi den zusteller das einfach
abzustellen ist das nicht habe ich das
selber schultern wenn das paket dann weg
ist also es ist halt die frage wie bei
der ersatzzustellung einfach die frage
was akzeptiere ich sozusagen als meine
empfangsbereich wenn ich natürlich bei
der bestellung angeben ihr könnt das
einfach über meinen über einen zaun
werfen auf meinem grundstück dunn ist
dann auch die zustellung erfolgt wenn es
über den zaun geworfen wird deshalb
sollte man dem immer unbedingt
widersprechen
bitte nur persönliche übergabe
insbesondere bei teureren gegenständen
natürlich wird's teurer weil die
versandkosten sind teurer und das wird
ja dem besteller auch in aller regel
auferlegt das wird ein bisschen teurer
aber auf jeden fall sicherer muss ich
denn in diesem fall beweisen gut hier
gibt es ein beweisvideo von der kamera
muss sich beweisen dass das dann jemand
gestohlen hat oder ich brauche halten
zeugen ich kann wahrscheinlich relativ
schwer nachweisen dass jemand dieses
paket praktisch von meiner treppe
gestohlen hat oder naja wenn wir der
ersatzzustellung zugestimmt haben das
heißt wenn dieses erste paket was er
hinter entwendet wird wenn ich dazu
gestimmt habe dass das sozusagen im
offenen bereich einfach so auf die
stufen abgestellt wird dann ist es in
diesem moment zugestellt und dann ist
sozusagen der verkäufer aus seinen
verpflichtungen rechtlich raus und wenn
dann jemand anders kommt
klaut dann ist das sozusagen mein
eigenes risiko und deswegen ist es halt
auch wichtig wann das paket zugestellt
wurde wenn ich dieser ersatzzustellung
zustimme zugestellt trage ich das risiko
deshalb bitte von vornherein unbedingt
widersprechen also wir schauen mal wie
es in diesem fall jetzt weiter gehen
also der zuschauer aus braunschweig hat
jetzt
amazon eingeschaltet und hat auch dieses
video vorgelegt amazon prüft den fall
jetzt und wie es auch in einer früheren
stellungnahme hieß wir arbeiten mit dem
kunden an lösungen wir schauen also an
und wollen natürlich eventuell auch den
schaden wiedergutmachen eine endgültige
klärung steht noch aus aber tatsächlich
gut es ist halt ein ja ist es einen
diebstahl aber natürlich an kempkes hat
gesagt man kann hat ist quasi selber
schuld wenn man sich sein paket bis auf
die stufe zu stellen